[موسيقى]
نحن الشباب لنا الغدو ومجده المخلد اما
الحاضر فمقيد لكل عابر ضربا من بيت ابي
وقهرا من مغير مغاير بلاد العرب اوطاني
فكيف الذل اوطاني على انقاذ حاضره او في
محابس المحن لك يا قدس السلام
وسلاما يا بلادي او غلافين الخصام والسلام
للاعادي سجل انا عربي واعمل مع رفاق الكدح
في محجر المحجر اقفل والرفاق غابه نصفهم
ماتوا في مركب متهلل ابحر ونصفهم ضاعوا في
غربه فروا من المخفر بلاد العرب اوطاني
ستبقى لاخر الزمن ستمحوا من محتل ياء
النسبه في وطني الى العناويه
قمه لم الشمل العربي هل زاد عرب تفرقا
بين المغرب والجزائر صحراء وخريطهتان
عون من القصر الجمهوري الى قصر شخصي
زنسكي دول عربيه ستجوع بسبب روسيا
هندوس يحتفلون برئاسه سوناك حكومه
بريطانيا
سفاح مجزره التضامن حر طليق في سوريا
هيفاء وهبي ذهب المكياج فبان المرج
[موسيقى]
باعلان الجزائر اختتمت اعمال القمه
العربيه الحاديه والثلاثين بعد يومين من
الاجتماعات على مستوى القاده
البيان الختامي لم يخرج عن مالوف بيانات
القمم السابقه وبنودها المكرره حول مركزيه
القضيه الفلسطينيه وتفعيل العمل العربي
المشترك وحمايه الامن القومي العربي مرحبا
قمه لم الشمل بدلت الجزائر جهدها ليكون
لها من اسمها نصيب لكن ما افسده الدهر لن
تصلحه قمه لامه في قمه التفرق والغياب عن
العمل القومي المشترك القمه استبقت باشكال
جديده قديمه بين الجزائر والرباط
انما بين المغرب والجزائر اخوه دين ونسبوا
اعراق وعائلات واحده بقلوب موحد موحده لكن
نقطه تفصل بينهما ايضا وتكمل تحت كرسي
الياء في كلمه خريطه تسحب واحده من
النقطتين فتتحول الخريطه الى خربطه الى
الاشكال الذي لابد للاجيال ان تكمل
اعمارها بدونه قناه الجزائر الدوليه قناه
اخباريه حديثه حذفت نقطه الخريطه فجعلتها
خريطتين مغربيه وصحرابيه غربيه ضمن رسم
لخريطه العالم العربي ما استدعى احتجاجا
مغربيا كاد يفجر الاجتماع على الوزاريه
التحضيري للقمه العربيه واعتذرت بعدها
قناه الجزائر الدولي وعلى خلفيه قيام قناه
الجزائر الدوليه الفانتات ميوزه بنشر
خريطه للعالم العربي على موقعها
الالكتروني تخالف الخريطه التي تعتمدها
جماعه الدول العربيه مما اثر تحفظ الوفد
المغربي واكدت الامانه العامه ان الجامعه
العربيه لا تعتمد خريطه الرسميه مبين
عليها الحدود السياسيه للدول العربيه
وانها تتبنى خريطه للوطن العربي بدون
اظهار للحضور بين الدول تعزيزا لمفهوم
الوحده العربيه
طار ايضا الى نيويورك مع مراسل قناه سكاي
نيوز عربيه السابق لان اداره القناه
اقالته من وظيفته بعد اعتراض السفير
المغربي لدى الامم المتحده عمر هلال على
سؤاله الذي اعتبره استفزازيا واتهممه بانه
يمثل حكومه الجزائر ولا يمثل سكاي نيوز
وعريضه من جنوبها من امريكا الجنوبيه الى
افريقيا السؤال لماذا كل خطاباتكم
وتدخلاتكم تتجهمون الجزائر حتى انه اليوم
في مداخالتكم ذكرتم الجزائر اكثر من ذكر
جبهه البوليساريو وكانت تتفضل تذكر اسمك
وتمثل اي جهه
عربيه سكاي نيوز عربيه تتكلم اسم الجزائر
الان
ماذا عن خريطه فلسطين الاخذ بالتاكل يوما
بعد يومين رئيس الولايات المتحده يكرر
للمره الخمسه الاف وقطع تعبيره ويضيف
اثناء استقباله الرئيس الاسرائيلي انه
يقول ذلك بصفته مسيحيه مخلصا ويقول لو لم
تكن اسرائيل موجوده لكان علينا ايجادها
اسرائيل لكنا قد اوجدناها
واقول ذلك
شخص مسيحي مخلص هذا هاجس مشترك عميق
يجمعنا في نفس اللقاء احتفل الرئيسان
الامريكي والاسرائيلي بترسيم الحدود
البحريه بين لبنان واسرائيل بواسطه
امريكيه
والمفارقه انه في لبنان ايضا احتفل الرئيس
السابق ميشال عون في اخر ايامه الرئاسيه
بترسيم الحدود البحريه مع الجانب
الاسرائيلي فيما يبقى الترسيم متعثرا مع
الجانب السوري موت سيدونج مؤسس جمهوريه
الصين الشعبيه يقول يجب ان ندعم كل ما
يعرضه العدو ونعارض كل ما يدعمه العدو بيد
زوج ونخبه غازل البحر المتوسط والاعتراف
باسرائيل بالروايه العبريه وبن نفي
اللبناني احتفل الرئيسان الامريكي جو بيدا
والاسرائيلي اسحاق هيرتوج بالتفاهم الذي
تم التوصل اليه لترسيم الحدود البحريه بين
اسرائيل ولبنان ووصفا بيضا التفاهما بانه
اتفاق تاريخي
دوله معاديه بدوله اسرائيل في اتفاق مكتوب
امام المجتمع الدولي باسره ولكنه عمل لا
اكثر بالنسبه للبنان
سياسيه وزير سابق من حزب الله هو وئام
وهاب يرى ان ترسيم الحدود مع اسرائيل يعني
سلاما مستداما معها فمن نصدق الرئيس عون
ام يائير لبيد انا رايي رحنا على سلامته
ما نضحك على بعضنا
عسلام مستمر
احنا هون ذهبنا الى سلام مستدام امبارح
فخامه الرؤوس لا قلت لي سلام وساده عسلام
الرئاسيه غادر ميشيل عون القصر الجمهوري
الى قصر شخصيا جديد بدت واحه تنضم الى
بقيه وحاتي زعماء لبنان في وسط جهنم التي
بشر اللبنانيين بها وتكشف الصور بناء
حديثا وعصريا ويقع على مساحه 2000 متر
مربع وهي عباره عن ثلاث طبقات مع طبقه
سفليه وبلغ التكلفه البناء سته ملايين
دولار وهو تافيت وزغاريد انت الرئيس
الجمهوريه مصر عبده الى الرابيه حيث كان
بانتظاره زفه بترحب بعوده القائد للحجات
الى البشر اعمده الشوارع قصر بعبدا
بالرابيه بمناصره التيار الوطني الحر
واعلام الحزب واعلام لبنان والسيارات اللي
جاي من مختلف المناطق اللبنانيه الى
اللقاء برئيس ومويكه مراسيم موجدارته من
القصر الرئاسي
نهايته مبسوطه اي فرحانه باللبناني حاله
ناشطه عونيه مبسوطه بانجازها وحيد ذكرته
للرئيس عون وهو كما قالت انه ازاح عن
الحكم الرئيس سعد الحريري الذي له انجاز
وحيد يذكر في فتره عون وهو انه اوصل مثال
عون الى الحكم في الصفقه الشهيره
ببلده مبسوطه لانه الرئيس فلل الحريره
العون لم يترك الرئاسه لرئيس بل حاول هزت
تفسيرات الدستوريه التي تنص على تولي
الحكومه مجتمعه صلاحيات الرئاسه الشاغره
فقبل استقاله حكومه مستقيله كما يدق الماء
ليصبح ماء مطقوقه شهور اريد له ان يتضعف
هكذا قرا خصوم الرئيس اللبنانيه المنصرف
ميشال عون اعلانه التوقيع على لاستقاله
الحكومه
وقعت مرسومه كبار الحكومه مستقيلا
اجراء وصف بالاستثنائي وغير المسبوق وانشا
جدلا الدستوريا خلال كل مراحل مسؤولياته
العسكريه والسياسيه قبل ان تجد لبناني
واحدا محايدا ازاء الجنرال عون فاما مؤيد
له في الصميم واما
كالصحفي سمو ابو فاضل الذي تجاوز كل
الخطوط الحمراء ولا ياقات مع الرئيس عون
ومع الرئيس نجيب ميقاتي لكنه لبنان الذي
تنفجر فيه قنبله شبه نوويه ولا يحدث شيء
بعدها نعرض الفيديو نقلا عن اس اي مع
التحفظته
كبير هو انسان زمي دفا على الناس ثمن
حياته دمر البلد 89 بالنتيجه لم يسال مساء
على سوريا مساء على المعتقلين انسان وصوله
بتنزل في اقصى العقوبه لم ارتكبه بحق
الوطن والمسيحيين واللبنانيين رئيس نجيب
لانه لانه تبهدل من رئيس ثاني
[موسيقى]
الرئيس الروسي فلاديمير بوتين يؤكد للغرب
اذا تعطلت مراحيضكم فلسنا نحن من عطا الله
اتهم الرئيس الاوكراني بولو دي ميرسي
موسكو بتهديد الامن الغذائي للجزائر ومصر
واليمن وبانجلاديش وبيتنا بالنسبه لمصر
حبذا لو تطمئن اخذ الاسكي لان اسعار
المواد الغذائيه لا يتدخل فيها احد لا انت
ولا بوتين ولا كل اصحاب السوبر ماركت مع
كامل الاحترام خالد الجندي يرفع المسؤوليه
عن القطاعين العام والخاص في موضوع ارتفاع
الاسعار فيقول المسعر هو الله وعلينا ان
لا نربط الجنيه بالدولار وانما بايماننا
بالله
مشيئه الله تعالى يا خالد لا يعجزها شيء
لكن ذلك لا يعطي الموسيئين والمتقاعدين من
تحمل المسؤولياتهم مهو المشاعر هو الله
احنا عاوزين نربط بقى العمله بتاعتنا مش
بالدولار ولا نربطها بالذهب عاوزين نربط
العمله بتاعتنا بايماننا بالله كل مكان
ايمانك بالله قوي كل ما كان اعتمادك على
رب العالمين انه ييسر الارزاق وانه خفض
الاسعار كبيره اعلاميين القاهره الاعلامي
المثالي احمد موسى بعكس خالد الجندي
يستشعر مع المواطن ويحذر التجار من اللعب
بالاسعار ويهددهم باقصى العقوبات سيذكر
اسم التاجر المخالف في برنامجه على الهواء
وده كمان دور وزاره التموين
دور جهاز حمايه المستهلك انك حملات ابعثوا
لنا قولولنا واللي هيعمل كده لازم على
الهواء نقول اهو الناس دول بيستغلوا ما
فيش ما يمنع
بهدف
المنصب يعود لويس انسيو لولاد سيلفا رئيسا
للبرازيل للمره الثالثه لولو تقدم بفارق
على المرشح
واليمني المتطرف جاهير
بوناروبا رئيسا للبرازيل مره جديده متفوقه
على جرير بولسنارو الذي بدا وكانه يستنجد
في حملته باسرائيل وبالكنيسه التبشيريه
اما عن اسرائيل فقد عبر عن تعاطفه معها
بوضع عالمها على صدر زوجته تجولت به على
مراكز الاقتراع رافعه علامه النصر في
اليوم الانتخابي الطويل فلم يشفع لزوجها
قميصه علم اسرائيل الذي لا بد من له
والتصرف بمائه
اما عن الكنيسه فهي تفضل بوليسانارو
اليمني على لولا ده سيلفا اليسرى المنحدر
من نقابات عمال المنازل في هذه الكنيسه
التبشيريه القس الياس وصلوا حشد المؤمنين
من اجل مرشح اليمين بوسنيرو دون ذكر اسم
هذا الاخير خوفا من اختراق القانون
الانتخابي على ابواب الجوله الثانيه
يوصل والقصص حشد الصفوف والتاثير على من
لم يحسم قراره بعد
في طقس دينيا يقام في الهند تحت عنوان
عباده البقر يتمدد متدينون هندوس على
الارض لتدوس الابقار واجسادهم وهم يعتقدون
ان ذلك يمنحهم البركه
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
ترتفع حراره الاحتفال بعباده البقر في
بلده غوماتورا وتحتدم منافسات المصارعه
بروث البقر وفق شبكه ايرون نيوز التي نقلت
ان اهل البلده يعبدون برجوارسامي ولديهم
اعتقاد ديني راسخ بان الههم ولد في روث
البقر لذلك يقام له مهرجان سنوي عابق بروث
البقر المفروس في ساحات الاحتفال ثم يتم
جمعه ونقله بعد ذلك الى معبد القريه
ودائما علانيه تحصل البركه بحسب ايرانيوس
تخيلوا انه مع كل هذه القدسيه التي تمنحها
جماعات المت جديده الهندوس لروث البقر ثم
يرون كل يوم الابقار تذبح وتشوى وتؤكل حول
العالم فكيف ينتقمون لمقدسهم ومما من
الحلقه الاضعف يجيب راسب النباتي من
المسلمين المواطنين الهنود الاصليين
كغيرهم والذين تحطوا عددهم مئتين مليون
نسمه
هدموا بيوتهم واحراقها امس سعاده عند
السلطات المحليه اقدمت السلطات قبل يومين
على هدم 40 منزلا لعوائل مسلمه في قريه
خداك في العاصمه السياسيه ظله وتاتي مثل
هذه الانباء في الوقت الذي يحشدون حزب
الهندوسيه المتطرف بقياده رئيس الوزراء
نارين دامودي اتباعه للنيل والانتقام من
اتباعه الديانه الاسلاميه
وشهدت مدن عده في الهند حالات مشابهه حيث
اقدمت الشرطه والبلديه في الفتره الاخيره
على تهديم منازل المئات من المسلمين رئيس
الحكومه البريطانيه الجديد ريشي سوناك ذو
الاصول الهنديه لا يشارك في المهرجانات
الهندسيه الصاخبه بل يكتفي باداء الصلوات
وطقوس التقديس كما يثني على الكتاب المقدس
عند الهندوس
اطفال بعدا دينيا على فوزي سوناتا برئاسه
الحكومه البريطانيه ورؤوا في تزامن الحدث
مع عيد الديوالي الهندوسي انتصارا للخير
على الشر فيما دعا برلمانيون معتدلون الى
الاقتداء بالتنوع البريطاني وسماحي لغير
الهندوس بتبئ منصب رئيس الوزراء في الهند
هل يقبل المسلمون في المقابل عندما يشكلون
اغلبيه في دوله ماكاباكستان مثلا ايتها
حكومتهم وغير لدينهم فلماذا تطلب من الاخر
اي يقدم لك ملست مستعدا على تقديمه له
في مقابل المقابل يسال بهيج هل نجحت في
الاصل تجربه حكم الاقليات للاغلبيه في بعض
دول الشرق الاوسط بدءا من فلسطين ان
الديموغرافيا هي التي تصنع التاريخ نشرت
صحيفه الجارديان البريطانيه تفاصيل جديده
صادمه عن مجزره التضامن في دمشق وقالت ان
ضابطه المخابرات السوريه المسؤوله عنها
امجد يوسف لا يزال يعملوا في قاعده عسكريه
خارج دمشق وان الفيديو الذي نشر عن
المجزره ليس الا القليل من حجم الجرائم
الوحشيه التي ارتكبت في المجزره
انا لم ابوك ما زلت حيا انما
مات الضمائرهم خرج وزير الخارجيه السوريه
فيصل المقداد عن صمته واوضح للاعلامي
العماني موسى الفرعي سبب تعفه في دمشق عن
الرد على الهجمات والغارات الاسرائيليه
وذلك رافه بكل مسافر على متن طائره مدنيه
تعبر فوق سوريا من سوء حظي ضحايا مجزره
التضامن انهم كانوا على الارض وليس في
الجو هم يستغلون مرور بعض الطائرات
المدنيه ويطلقون النار من تحتها او من
فوقها
في هذه الحاله عندما ترد الصواريخ السوريه
ستصيب قد تصيب بعض الطيران المدني وبعد
ذلك يقع اللوم علينا لذلك نحن لا نفعل
وزير الخارجيه الالمانيه الاسبق زق مار
جبريل انتقد ما وصفه بالغطرسه الالمانيه
المثيره للاستئزاز تجاه قطر وذكر
المتغطرسين بان الماني يستغرقت عقودا
لتصبح لبراليه حمله المعادين للثقافه
الاسلاميه التي تستهدف مونديال قطر ردت
عليها الدوحه بسماحه الاسلام وبحديث
الرسول محمد عليه واله الصلاه والسلام
في قطر كتب عليها بعض الاحاديث النبويه
للتعريف بدين الاسلامي للقادمين الى كاس
العالم الذي تنطلق فعاليته في العشرينا
نوفمبر المقبله وانتشرت صور كثيره
للجداريات التي تستهدف تعريف الملايين
ملايين الوافدين على منطقه الشرق الاوسط
والخليج من اجل حضور العرس العالمي
بسماحه يدين الاسلامي
في المتفرقات الا يحق لاقارب الوزير في
العراق اي يحتفلوا بتعيين قريبهم في
الوزاره اما وان الوزاره للتربيه فكان
المستحب معركه ناريه مع الهواء وكاننا
نشاهد فيديو لمعركه من حرب ماء لكن
المفاجاه ان هذه المشاهد لاحتفال لاقارب
وعائلته وزير التربيه الجديد ابراهيم نامس
الجبوري في مناسبه تسلمه الماضي
بل في عالم اخر واهتمامات اقل ما يقال
فيها انها عجيبه وتحتاج لدراسات المجتمعيه
المكياج ساح فاختفت هيفاء وبقي وهبه
عنوانه عشرات ملايين التفاعلات التي سجلت
مع ظهوره هيفاء وهبي على الواقع مختلفه عن
الصور والفيديوهات في الاعلام وذلك بعد
الانتقادات التي طالتها عقب ح في السعوديه
مما فعاليات موسم الرياض الى جانب الفنانه
اللبنانيه اليسا
[موسيقى]
حكايه الختام هذا الاسبوع قصه كبيره من
مذيع خارق يملك القدره على البرمجه
المسبقه للمدمات ورؤيتها ثم تفسيرها على
الهواء ليطلق احدهم عليه لقب ابن شيرين
تيمنا ببن سيرين رحمه الله لو لم يستحضر
اسم الرسول محمد عليه الصلاه والسلام في
منامه او حكايته لكنت الان اخبركم قصه
اخرى لكن المذيعه المصريه ابراهيم طنطاوي
يذكرنا بمقطع عادل امام بلدي طنطا وانا
احب اعيش طنطا الى اللقاء تحيا مصر
ويحيى فقامت السيد الرئيس عبد الفتاح
السيسي قائد الامه العربيه
بصراحه حصل معي كده موقف يعني
جسمي لغايه دلوقت يعني شايل ومهما قلت او
وصفت او عبرت
مش هوفي اللي انا هاحكيه على حضراتكم الان
حقه
حلمت حلم
حلم ده لفخامه السيد الرئيس عبد الفتاح
السيسي اللي انا باصفه بقائد الامه
العربيه
حلمت
بفخامه الرئيس
انه في مكان
زي جنه
وبيشتكي للنبي عليه الصلاه والسلام
قاعد ما بين يد النبي عليه الصلاه والسلام
قال له ارفع راسك يا عبد الفتاح فلا يحزنك
قولهم
فبدا بالبكاء
النبي عليه الصلاه والسلام قال له ارفع
راسك يا قائد خير اجناد الارض
فلا يحزنك قولهم
فازداد فقامت السيد الرئيس بالبكاء
قال له ارفع راسك فلا يحزنك قولهم انا
نعلم ما يسرون وما يعلنون
كانت رؤيا والله العظيم لحد الان شفت كده
لما
يعني بيحصل حاجه كده جسم الواحد بيشعر من
شده اللي هو شافه
طنطا ولا احب اعيش اونطه
[موسيقى]